[Music]
all right we're live on the computer
machine I'm Dave Rubin this is the
rubben report it's October 17th 2023 I
don't know why I'm doing that accent but
I haven't been very funny lately and
this is the voice I started doing what
can I tell you we're uh on Rumble we're
on locals we're on YouTube Share
subscribe tap all that good stuff
postgame show at locals at Ruben report.
locals.com and before we do anything you
know I am not above a correction I like
actually making corrections I like when
you guys actually say Dave you might
want to take a look at that or anything
else and I do want to make a correction
and and a public apology actually to
someone who I've already apologized to
privately but I have absolutely no
problem doing this whatsoever uh Julia
Hartley uh is the British journalist who
interviewed Douglas Murray in those two
clips that we showed you up top
yesterday uh and it sounded like she was
asking Douglas why Israel doesn't
respond proportionately and Douglas had
of course you know why they don't
respond proportionately to the Hamas
attacks and Douglas had a brilliant
answer of course like you know how do
you respond like okay let's get 1300 of
their women and babies and rape and burn
them and the rest of it uh I was a
little critical of Julia uh without
having really understood the breath of
her work I was just watching from uh
these two clips and very quickly it
started in the live chat during the show
which I didn't realize till the end uh
you guys all like tons of you alerted us
and in the locals chat and everywhere
else alerted us that she she is quite a
good journalist I've subsequently done
some research on her turned out that she
followed my me I immediately messaged
her and apologized uh and I also
mentioned to her that I was going to do
a public apology right now uh so she was
basically playing Double's Advocate she
wasn't arguing as many MSNBC Hamas TV
presenters do that Israel should have a
proportionate response she was Playing
devil's advocate uh and and giving
Douglas an opportunity really to show
how ridiculous uh that piece is show her
Twitter bio for just a second second
because then very quickly once I found
her uh she's got a good sense of humor
too she is a journalist broadcaster
event host speaker and woman without a
penis so if she isn't getting enough
hate for not being a horrible journalist
in a time of moral cowardice uh she also
doesn't have a penis so there you go
anyway moral cowardice cowardice
actually is going to be the theme of
today's show because what I'm seeing
right now is an awful lot of people who
are leaning into truth it's it's nice
for me at least that so many of the
people that I've been associated with
over the years the people who I think
have been kind of the best of the best
the Dan Banos the Megan Kelly's the
Jordan Peterson types uh that they're
really shining right now there's a
there's a a
morality and a Clarity and a historical
understanding of the land and the
geopolitics and all that that really
they're trying to get out there to the
rest of their ability just as I am
trying to do the same uh then there's a
certain set of people who have
completely gone off the deep end and are
defending people who would gladly behead
them and it's like you know you can put
your head in the sand but you're just
going to get beheaded a little higher up
on the neck that's how it works like
it's it's just pathetic but then there's
sort of these people that out of I would
say cowardice and a sort of
inability to say what is true because
they never want to offend anyone uh are
actually becoming maybe the biggest
problem right you know there was old uh
line about the Holocaust that uh it was
it was the cowardice of the people just
to speak up and say what was right you
knew who the bad guys were right like
the Nazis who were running around
killing people it was easy for people to
point to that and that was not actually
most people but it's all of the other
people who just do nothing in a in a
time of horror and barbarity that that
is a a separate problem unto itself and
I want to shine a light on some of those
people because I think maybe those
people can wake up I don't think that
they're necessarily bad people I think
some of them are a little confused about
the history and all that but some of
them have been so bludgeoned by the
culture wars and that's why I'm going to
relate Today's Show to all of the woke
nonsense the Dei stuff and largely
what's going on with our corporations
and everything else like it has left a
generation of us and a culture an
American culture that doesn't largely
know what is good and bad what are boys
and girls and that the guys doing the
beheading generally are worse than the
people being beheaded and of course I'll
give you some solutions because the
solution really it's not only a
spiritual solution and a and a deep
solution within you to stand up for
what's right because no one is going to
come save you you but occasionally we
can get some uh good political leaders
to uh to usher in some good governance
and wouldn't that be refreshing and it
looks like it's happening right now
because uh Jim Jordan is due it sounds
like I don't want to count my chickens
before they hatch with this ridiculous
Congress but it sounds like he will
become speaker of that so we're going to
get to all of that uh but first let me
talk to you guys about Patriot Supply uh
the
segue do you guys get the feeling
something Unthinkable is going to happen
soon I sure but with all the
distractions and smoke screens in the
media we probably won't see it coming
that's why it's smart to invest in
emergency food today I have a lot of
this stuff by the way guys A wise man
once said it's better to have it and not
need it than to need it and not have it
my Patriots Supply is the nation's
leader in emergency food storage you can
go to prepare withth ruben.com and
you'll save 25% on my Patriot supplies
three-month emergency food kits you'll
enjoy a wide variety of delicious meals
providing over 2,000 calories a day for
Optimum strength under stress stock up
now before everyone else panics free
shipping is automatic and your order
ships fast go to prepare withth
ruben.com prepare withth ruben.com and
now back to me that does remind me that
actually my schedule is cleared for the
rest of today uh because I'm going up uh
well I don't want to say where but I'm
going to buy a couple more guns we've
got some guns we're going to buy some
more guns and everyone should do
whatever they have to do to to take care
of them themselves and their property
and most importantly their family uh and
their loved ones so there you go okay so
the the theme as I said is sort of moral
cowardice and and how we end up in a
West W society that is so good right
like everything we've had here despite
the last couple years of craziness
everything that America has stood for
the freedoms all the people who've come
here the multiculturalism that actually
has worked we are not a racist Society
we are not a bigoted Society we don't we
are not prejudicial towards anyone based
on their religion or sexuality or any of
those stupid things right but somehow
our success has actually left us in many
ways from a cultural perspective unable
to delineate between good and evil so uh
look I don't I'm not playing this clip
to bash Pete Davids in I have literally
never seen a movie can someone name a
movie he's in he's a movie star right
he's in he's on SNL yeah he's kind of
like his movies are really
bad oh he just a comedian all right so
he's a comedian he's on SNL uh Saturday
Night Live and Saturday Night Live was a
comedy Institution for years America I
would say at the peak of America like
the the 70s ' 80s '90s into early 2000s
SNL was like a mirror to look back on us
right we needed satire to look back on
the ridiculous and make fun of our
politicians and and everything else but
you know that most of our comedy and our
drama everything went crazy woke so
nobody really pays that much attention
to asnl so I'm using this not to bash
this guy okay and especially because he
talks about how his father died in 911
here but I want to show you the sort of
equivocation that these people make that
it's they can't really say who good guys
and bad guys are everyone is sort of
equal etc etc uh this is Pete Davidson
at the opening of Saturday Night Live
just two days
ago this week we saw the horrible images
and stories from Israel and Gaza and I
know what you're thinking who better to
comment on it than Pete
Davidson well uh in a lot of ways uh I
am a good person to talk about it
because when I was 7 years old uh my dad
was killed at a terrorist attack so I
know something about what that's like um
I saw so many terrible pictures this
week of children suffering isra children
and Palestinian children and uh it took
me back to a really horrible horrible
place and um you know no one in this
world deserves to suffer like that you
know especially not kids you know um
after my dad died my mom tried uh pretty
much everything she could do to cheer me
up I remember one day when I was eight
uh she got me what she thought was a
Disney movie uh but it was actually the
Eddie Murphy standup special
Delirious uh and we played it in the car
on the way home and when she heard the
things Eddie Murphy was saying uh she
tried to take it away um but then she
noticed something uh for the first time
in a long time I I was laughing again um
I don't understand it I really don't and
I never will but sometimes comedy is
really the only way forward through
tragedy um you know my heart is with
everyone whose lives have been destroyed
uh this week um but tonight I'm going to
do what I've always done in the face of
tragedy and that's try to be
funny um remember I said
try and live from New York it's Saturday
okay there's there's a bunch of things
that I want to address here sorry I was
fiddling I'm writing down a 100 things
that he said there first off it's it's
odd that he said his dad was killed in a
terror attack his dad was killed on 911
he he was a firefighter on 9911 in New
York City I don't know why he just said
a terror attack and didn't address that
there probably is some reason why right
it might make people think uh who did
911 right and that they have a little
something in in common with the people
that just burn babies alive right his
dad was killed by jihadists waging a
holy war it's the same thing that is
happening right now so that that's a
little bit odd and again I just want to
be clear I'm not this personally about
him right it's NBC is a giant
Corporation they write this for him and
this is the message they want to get out
he immediately opens by saying that he
feels bad for Israeli children and
Palestinian children now we know first
off that the Israeli children who were
burned to death and are now kidnapped
and everything the intention the
absolute intention was the horror and
the savagery and everything else and
it's and it's just beyond imagination
heads split open the rest of it you
either ether seen it or you haven't but
it exists I assure you the Palestinian
children who are dying are dying because
of Hamas right we showed you the videos
yesterday of Israel literally dropping
leaflets hey we know Hamas is in this
building their main headquarters are
under a hospital we they are using them
as human Shields so they fire Rockets
with kids next to them right which you
shouldn't do if you were a civilized
society and then they use them as human
Shields knowing the Israelis usually
won't attack where the kids are but some
kids are going to die is it is just part
of War uh by the way the Rockets are
still being shot right at this very
moment right they're still being shot so
when you see AOC and ilhan Omar and
other members of the Hamas caucus ask
for a ceasefire it's interesting that
nobody's asking they're not asking you
would if you wanted this to stop and you
thought Israel was just so evil you'd
say to Hamas hey all right you did what
you did okay we kind of dig it but we
won't say that um how about you just
stop shooting Rockets because then it
would make our case better if everyone
saw oh you weren't even shooting Rockets
so now it's indefensible this wouldn't
be my argument but their argument could
be now it's indefensible what Israel is
doing by attacking but they're still
shooting Rockets right now they still
have 200 uh about 200 hostages we don't
know the exact number and we don't know
how many of them are American ilhan Omar
AOC Etc have not called for American
hostages to be released so I play this
because he's immediately equivocating he
can't say which one is worse and which
one is better like how do you think the
comedy scene is in Gaza dude when you're
trying to be irreverent and fight the
power that's what comedy used to be it's
not what it is anymore certainly on SNL
like do you think they allow that in
Gaza they do allow it in Israel right
they really do uh so this equivocation
this nothing is better nothing is worse
no no people are moral more moral and
less moral it's it's complete nonsense
was there anything else I wanted to get
to there um so oh well he ends it with
everyone whose lives have been
destroyed like oh as if these things are
completely equal so you got it so so
that's sort of the aoral neutrality that
I think we're getting so much of out out
of our cultural uh lens but I want to
get into the political part too with a
couple videos from some of the members
of the Hamas caucus but before we do
that uh let me talk to you guys about
TWC Health guys I want to introduce you
to the wellness company and specifically
their medical emergency kit awake
doctors like Peter McCulla have started
the wellness company to build a parallel
Health Care system and bring about
change in a corrupt failing system part
of that change is helping you to take
control of your health and supporting
you through whatever the next thing is
that gets thrown our way most people
don't trust healthc care right now in
fact 40% over 40% of Americans say they
would avoid a doctor or a hospital
unless it was a catastrophic situation
that's where the wellness company's
medical emergency kit comes in eight
potentially life-saving medications for
you to keep on hand in times of need
natural disasters supply chain shortages
medical emergencies Etc uh rest easy
knowing that you have emergency
antibiotics antivirals antiparasitics uh
to help you and your family stay safe
the kit includes a comprehensive guide
book so you'll never have to guess how
much to take or when to take it and if
you're like me and you want to make sure
your family is prepared for the
unexpected go to tww c. rubben and use
code Ruben use code ruin for 15% a check
out that's tww c. Health uh Cod rubben
tww c. Health rubben Cod rubben for 15%
off and now back to me did I say Reuben
enough times there okay so that's sort
of the the a the aoral position right
like it's a sort of neutral position and
I would hope that over time and this is
why I'm not trying to attack Pete
Davidson that people like him will
realize oh there's a set of people that
would gladly kill you and and not be for
your Progressive values or for comedy or
for free speech or any of the things
that I think you care about Pete
Davidson but I don't want to attack him
on that because you want to welcome
these people over and as I've been
saying I'm seeing it right I played
clips of The View yesterday where the
women were not completely insane so you
want to it's tough sometimes because
they've been wrong on so many things but
you want to try to welcome these people
over as they are you know kind of
ingesting the red pill for the first
time but then there's another another
set of people who are not neutral they
are actually apologists for terrorist
organizations they are usually a group
of people who have no sense of what the
history is or what reality is or what
they would do if their family was
beheaded or their child was burned to
death uh and at the top of that list I
put these members of the Hamas caucus
and of course I'm talking about AOC and
ilhan Omar
and Rashida TB there's about five others
of them uh here is AOC doing one of her
little handheld videos uh and she's very
concerned she has not called for the
release of the American hostages she has
basically not said anything uh other
than a little bit of lip service about
the dead Israelis she didn't share any
videos about the original attack
anything like that she's mostly
concerned the American responsibility
remember at least 20 American hostages
but the most thing that America should
care about right now it's the
responsibility to help the
Palestinians our
responsibility is to the stability and
the security of the region that means
being able to support uh not support yes
Israel in its defensive capacities right
in its abil in in in that context but it
also means that the United States has a
responsibility to ensure accountability
to human rights to prevent the ethnic
cleansing of Palestinians and to ensure
that Horrors do not happen in the names
of victims who do not want their tragedy
used to justify further violence and
Injustice right okay first of all she
farted at the end of that thing I don't
know if you heard that but that we did
not add that and many people have done
like forensic this is the beauty of the
internet even in in terrible times she
legit beefed at the end of that thing so
enjoy that that's and you know
considering that's what she's spewing
out of her mouth the whole time that's
not surprising so so again her number
one uh concern is the responsibility
that America will do something about the
Palestinians she has not asked for the
American hostages to be released think
how profoundly insane that is uh she
gets also very nervous when she has to
say anything remotely decent about
Israel but when she even says that they
should be you know in essence she's
saying we should help them defend
themselves well sometimes defense you
cannot play defense all the time with an
army occasionally you can't just always
be like okay they killed a couple of us
we'll kill a couple of them you can't
you can't do that if in a sport you
can't always be on defense soccer you
can't always be on the defensive side of
the field basketball you can't always
play defense you got to score some
points every now and again that's how
you win right so sometimes a military
has to do things sometimes they would
prefer not to do them because they know
that the bad guys will use that so that
useful idiots will start screaming about
ethnic cleansing and everything else but
I want to I want to show you a video
that we played the other day it's worth
repeating and I hope you will share this
video with everyone you know we will
make a standalone clip out of this video
uh if we have not already because this
is AOC in 2017 just at the beginning of
AOC and and she is a character character
actor she is a larper she has no
expertise in anything she was a
bartender she's a racist she's a buffoon
here she is listen to her explain she's
very passionate about Israel and the
Palestinians uh but listen under the
most basic questioning how she folds
quicker than a wet paper bag geopolitics
and the war midd East is very different
than people expressing their First
Amendment right to protest
well yes but I also think that what
people are starting to see at least in
in the occupation uh of of Palestine is
um just an increasing crisis of
humanitarian condition and that to me is
just where I tend to come from on this
issue you use the term the occupation of
pales
what did you mean by that oh
um I think it what I meant is like the
the settlements that are increasing in
some of these areas and and places where
um where Palestinians are experiencing
uh difficulty in access to uh their
housing and homes do you think you can
expand on that yeah I mean I think I'd
also just I I am not the expert on
geopolitics on this issue you yes you're
a that's what you are all
right all right what I'm trying I'm
trying you know what I mean I'm trying
um she has no idea what she's talking
about the occupation can you explain
what you mean by the occupation well I
just I the settlements so what she's
saying is she doesn't want Jews living
in a certain part of the world is there
any other place on Earth that AO AOC
would say a certain set of people of a
certain religion can't live there
especially people who have a bit of a
connection to that land as I've
repeatedly said and don't just follow me
on this check it for yourself the West
Bank we only call it the West Bank since
1967 it is called Judea and Samaria
that's what it's been called for
thousands of years Judea you'll never
believe who lived there right the hills
of Judea that's where the story of
Hanukkah that every freaking secular Jew
who doesn't know which way is Wednesday
right who hasn't gone to Temple in 20
years they know that the story of
Hanukkah is the Jews defending the
Judean Hills the macbes defending the
Judean Hills from the Greeks who were
the Invaders okay but even again you
don't even have to care about the
history it's just very fascinating she
doesn't want a couple Jews having houses
uh in the West Bank by the way when we
were in Israel about 6 months ago we
went to the West Bank and it was largely
peaceful it really was and we went to a
winery it was called the uh sagot Winery
PS a g o t Winery and there were Arabs
working there and there were Jews
working there and Muslims and bins
working there and it was and everyone
was friendly and nice that's what these
people that's what AOC would love to
fray there was also um remember Soda
Stream I assum it still exists I think
it was an Israeli company originally you
could make your own soda you know you
could carbonate your water or whatever
they had a plant in the West Bank it was
paying extremely high wages to Arab
Muslims and then people like AOC were
all for this BDS boycott Israel movement
so they closed the plant and those
people lost all their jobs so that's
what they want but the point is there's
no other place on Earth where AOC
doesn't want a certain people certain
set of people to live because of their
religion it only applies to Jews in the
ancient homeland of the Jews it's a
little bizarre but these people people
we we shouldn't be surprised is what
I've been trying to say to you because
so much of leftism has been based on
lies and confusions and everything else
and then it leads to horrible policies
right so when everyone was saying five
six years ago when Jordan Peterson and
Ben Shiro and a bunch of us were talking
about this everyone kept saying oh these
are just college kids when they get out
to the real world the real world will
smack them in the face they'll wake up
but the real world the real world folded
we now know
that then what happens the policies that
these idiots vote for do horrible things
check out this tweet from the
post-millennial representative jbal
Jamal Bowman this is the clown who
pulled the fire alarm in Congress last
week said that the US ought to start
bringing in Palestinian refugees uh let
me be very clear about this the US
should bring in zero Palestinian
refugees uh some people have tried to
make this equate you know this
difference okay well the Palestinians
are the people and Hamas is the
government and not they don't all
support what ever I don't see any
Palestinians out Marching In These
parades wherever they are they
supporters making a distinction right
there's very few people at the at the
Hamas parades going guys Hamas are the
bad guys stop beheading people we should
have a peaceful movement there's
literally nobody but if you think our
border agents like if they're like okay
bring over 100,000 Palestinians first
off there's absolutely no reason we
should do it zero absolutely zero reason
right um but if you think our border
agents will be able to ask them
questions and delineate how many these
people just want to kill all the Jews or
hate America or anything else like no it
simply will not work it's worth seeing
this this image uh because I've been
posting this a lot I don't know where it
came from originally but if you want the
image you can find it on my Twitter I
tweeted at AOC and Omar and Pressley and
TB and Bowman and Bush and Caesar and
Lee often uh they are the Hamas caucus
they will do anything that will be
against America that will be against
Freedom they simply do not care about
the American hostages again even if you
do not care about all the dead Israelis
right if you just don't care about that
I think there's reasons you should
because they will not stop with dead
Israelis but they don't care about the
American hostages or the dead Americans
right now they are calling for a
ceasefire rather than saying give us the
Americans or America might get involved
I I'm not even for American involvement
other than we should support Israel's
ability to defend
itself you get the point so so the
question is really has this rhetoric
influenced our colleges or have our
colleges influenced this rhetoric right
this was the Long March through the
institutions that the leftists you got
to give the devil his due they went into
our colleges decades ago and they
brainwashed generations of people who
now know no history and no biology or
anything else so here is a video of NYU
students New York University students I
used to hang down by this area all the
time removing posters feur feing missing
Israelis so a group of people put up
posters at NYU and it's it's all over
New York City of missing Israelis right
people whose families have been
butchered and killed and here are these
these tolerant and nobody's illegal and
peaceful and diverse uh Hamas supporters
uh pulling those posters
down
like think of the gall of this again
imagine you're just sort of you don't if
you don't care about any of this uh and
again I as I've said repeatedly like I
care about this I care about this
because I do care about Israel but
actually it's mostly because I care
about America and I care about freedom
and these battles these are no longer
local geopolitical battles these are
these are the battles of our time right
they they are and they're worldwide
right why did the Hamas leader call for
an international day of jihad uh on
Friday right an international Jihad not
just like an extra Jihad on the Jews
like it was an international one okay um
I want to throw a close-up of those
posters so these are the posters there
in the New York City subway so they're
not calling for death they're not
calling for murder or any saying
anything about a response or anything
else they're just saying these people
have been kidnapped we would like these
people back these young people these
children these women they've K they've
literally kidnapped grandmothers who are
Holocaust Survivors it's just it's just
absolutely insane and everyone should
get to know those two guys GS uh that we
just showed you the picture of cuz you
might uh you know I assume they're NYU
students they probably want jobs one day
and you might we have to think if you
were hiring by the way we are hiring a
an extra uh editor right now the Ruben
report is continuing to grow uh can you
make sure we don't hire those two chicks
all right we're putting that down um but
it continues at the universities and
it's not just the students again the
students are the pawns these kids don't
know what they're protesting they don't
know what they're saying they have been
fed lies forever and they're just pawns
you know what it reminds me of you
remember uh this is a I don't make too
often remember X-Men 3 you remember
X-Men 3 what was it called someone get
me what was X-Men 3 called the original
X-Men movies the third one when the Cure
they have the cure for the mutation yeah
uh and at the
end all Magneto what was it called The
Last Stand it was called and at the end
there's all these mutants that like the
bad guy mutants Magneto and all the bad
guy mutants and they know that and
they're trying to break into this place
to get this other mutant who has the the
quote unquote cure so that the mutants
will no longer be mutants and Magneto is
not happy about this because he believes
mutants should be mutants and mutants
should live free let's put aside the
mutant part of this for a moment they
realize there's going to be a big battle
right and Magneto has his main guys who
who are some of the main bad guys in uh
in X-Men he's got toad right he's got
Toad and he's got uh who yeah he's got
Jugger not and a couple of the other bad
guys and they're all ready to fight
right at the beginning and Magneto says
no no in the pawns
first Ian what's his name Ian mlen how
was that Magneto that was pretty good
and that's what they're doing these
people are just pawns you guys are just
being used and they don't you think
Hamas gives a about the
purple-haired douchebag who's out on the
streets of Dearborn Michigan you idiots
anyway it's not just the students that's
the point of all of this it is coming
from The Faculty it is coming from the
administration uh here is an image of
University of Michigan Professor his
name is Eric Gordon we should all get to
know this guy I'm sure he'd have a
lovely life in Hamas uh he has a little
gay face I would say this guy's probably
gay he's got he's got gay face to me
that strikes me as as gay face um here
he is tearing down posters of kidnapped
Israelis some of them US citizens being
held in Gaza and if you think that this
is not just so we've seen it in Dearborn
Michigan and we've seen it in New York
City um it's all over the place it's
even believe it or not and I don't think
this will last very long but I think it
was worth showing you uh even in the
streets of Florida yeah this is even in
Florida uh here are heras flags and um
oh they managed to bring some Taliban
Flags
[Applause]
too all right so one very brave young
girl with her Israeli flag there she's
not angry at anybody or anything else
basically the that flag now represents
is oh can we survive against the global
Jihad and a group of people that have
wanted to destroy us since the beginning
and these people uh free free Palestine
the implication is not oh let's have a
two-state solution it's let's wipe those
8 million Jews off the map by the way
there's about 2 million Muslims there
they'd have to go down to all of the the
Thai people 14 Thai people got killed
and blah blah blah okay fine um but they
have a Taliban flag there too did you
notice that it wasn't just the Hamas
flag and that is the Hamas flag by the
way uh there is no distinction between
the Palestinian flag and the Hamas flag
there's no again there's nobody out
there who's going I'm for freeing
Palestine Hamas is a bit
much okay okay um so it's everywhere
it's absolutely everywhere and I want to
show you how uh it's not just integrated
in our schools and the faculty like that
guy who you should all get to know um
it's it's really all over the place uh
so on CNBC business they had Mark Rowan
on now Mark Rowan is the chair of
University of Pennsylvania pen upen uh
their Wharton School of Business Wharton
School of Business by the way is is
probably the most well-known School of
Business in the entire world uh Donald
Trump even went to Wharton School of
Business uh here's Mark Rowan proud you
know proudly and doing the right thing
and it's so refreshing when someone does
the right thing calling out the
president of upen her name is Elizabeth
McGill because she refuses to issue a
strongly worded statement against Hamas
he he does a really nice job here take a
look well you this is your Alma moer so
let's let's just talk about how this
came about what was going through your
head uh what kind of conversations
you've had that led you to write this
look this is not at the end of the day
about Free Speech because I whether
people like it or not uh me personally
and most people support Free Speech
there are always going to be racists and
haters this is about a university
condone conference University professors
University supported and the inability
of leadership to exercise any sort of
Mor moral Clarity with respect to saying
this is hate this is anti-Semitism this
is racism but we're going to allow it
that condemnation should not be so hard
you know microaggressions are condemned
with extreme moral outrage and yet
violence particularly violence against
Jews anti-Semitism seems to have found a
place of Tolerance on the campus uh
protected by Free Speech uh president
Mill is not an anti-semite president
Mill is just not capable of exercising
moral leadership I love the line there
so I so I don't know anything obviously
about the president but if but beyond
what I'm hearing related to this I don't
think it's useful or um it's it's useful
or it's likely untrue let's say that
she's an anti-semite like that the
president of upen like hates Jews but
he's right what she is is a coward a
moral coward which also gets us back to
the Pete Davidson thing at the beginning
right that there's this group of people
that at these universities they've
called for microaggression and safe
spaces we've been doing this for years
right guys years and years I've been
called a Nazi and alt-right because I
was mocking this stuff for years that's
what they've been doing at colleges then
they get a group a bunch of kids out
there calling for genocide tearing down
uh you know leaflets and posters of kids
who are kidnapped blah blah blah blah
blah nobody condemning any of the
outrageous things that have happened and
not only do they allow it on campus and
we can have that discussion related to
free speech I believe in free speech and
free expression there there are some
caveats around that related to when you
start calling for the death of people it
could be a problem but it's but as his
point is it's not just that they're
allowing it right and he wants it to be
allowed within the confines of the law
it's that they won't issue a statement
saying oh there is a clear moral uh
position here to take which is that
killing innocent people is bad right
burning babies alive is bad so now I
want to go to another clip and you know
I've mentioned I've mentioned Dan banino
and mentioned Megan Kelly and and Jordan
Peterson I want to put Glenn Beck in
that group and and there's many others
by the way who've been so morally clear
on this but but one of my good buddies
over the last couple years doing this
Klay Travis Kay comes out of the World
of Sports right he was like a he never
worked for ESPN but he was like a ESPN
guy he's built outkick.com he's done
incredible stuff and he's become a great
cultural commentator as well and he's
also been going after identity politics
uh with the same veracity that I have
because he has seen it where I talk
about it from a political perspective
he's seen it how it's destroyed ESPN
it's destroyed professional sports and
all these things and watch how he
combines and he does a great job here
this is one of the things I've been
talking about and it's important because
you need to understand this is connected
it's not just something happening over
there it's something happening here in
the United States He connects the
insanity of identity politics to the
upside down conclusion that so many
people have come to when it comes to
Hamas and Israel I couldn't believe what
I saw happen all over this country and
all around the world there have been
people deciding to celebrate the murder
of all these innocent Jews you may have
seen it on the steps of the Sydney Opera
House you may have seen it in Times
Square you may have seen it in Dearborn
Michigan you might think to yourself how
in the world does this happen and it's
because of identity politics because
when you allow identity politics to
govern your worldview it's toxic the
majority of the Democrat Party now
believes that the Palestinians are the
right side and the Jewish people are the
wrong side in terms of who you should
support the people who have been arguing
aring that if you share opinions that
they dislike you are a Nazi are unable
to condemn and unwilling to condemn the
actual Mass Slaughter of Jews that is
the largest since the Nazis did it and
it's all because of identity politics
you know I've sent a lot of texts in the
last uh what 10 days or so uh telling
certain people that I'm I'm proud that
they're doing what they're doing and I'm
proud to be friends with them and I will
remind me to text Clay uh after this but
guys it doesn't start in college right I
think I think this is the other part of
this that's confusing people this has
been rotten to the core of all of our
public education so for this what were
we talking about a year ago a year ago
it was it was so much about don't say
gay and Ronda santis fighting wokeness
in schools and getting uh you know when
they wanted this AP African-American
studies course also to teach gender
queer theory that they have rotted the
minds of our children well before they
get into college right college is
supposed to teach you how to think not
what to think but they've already broken
their brains by the time they get there
so I want to show you this this is from
Ohio State this is their diversity
equity and inclusion faculty right this
is a this is the whole concept of a
diversity equity and inclusion
Department it's Dei but they should
really call it diversity inclusion
Equity d diie right because they in
essence want the rest of us to die and
that is what they want ultimately
they're out on the streets cheering for
it uh here is Ohio State's Dei faculty
discussing Ed education topics for white
and black kids K through 12 K through 12
these people are absolute racist frauds
go wouldn't need a black lives matter
movement black lives mattered in the
schoolhouse right um so in many respects
you know we begin kind of this white
supremacy understanding this anti-black
understanding through K12 education the
first time that school children are
introduced to black people historically
is Through The Narrative of enslavement
Right Through The Narrative of
Oppression Right Through The Narrative
of white domination right um so so
here as we talk about antiblackness it's
like okay well you are forever a slave
right should we really be centering
white people and whiteness in a time of
political uprise that's centering black
people so language is a part of this
right gar right TJ we know this language
is a part of white domination white
language is a part of white supremacist
thought and so I have this hashtag that
I do on T Twitter save black English
right black
English black English you know who
speaking black English
speak black English it's I I wish we had
grabbed the clip of the guy speaking
Jive an airplane what are we doing what
are we doing it's so in everything they
said there was so insane the first time
people get introduced to black people is
through white domination and slavery I I
a good friend in elementary school I
think he was my first black friend we
didn't really think about it that way
his name was Tyrone we used to play
He-Man and gi. Joe I wasn't trying to
think about white
domination
now I probably woke up the kids now
I'm really screwed H all right it but
okay you see my point guys I'm trying to
you can see how what they've done is
they break these kids' brains right so
they they now you have kids with broken
brains who suddenly no kid is racist
there is no child born into this world
who is racist suddenly you're in third
grade and you're playing with your what
do kids play with now I was playing with
GI Joe and He-Man but what would a third
grader play with Ninja Turtles I feel
like they're always around right so
you're playing ninja turtles with your
friend and then some teacher tells you
that that that's because of white
supremacy because uh Splinter was white
or splinter I guess was Asian but the
turtles you get it none of it makes
sense whatever I just said makes as
little sense is what these people are
being taught okay that's the
point a little more a little more here's
a woke science teacher admitting that
they inject race into Elementary School
science race elementary school so that
they can train the mind of the young
person it goes back to the curriculum
what you're talking about in the class
and how to infuse um issues around race
and culture and class um into the
subject matter and as a science teacher
I have to do that intentionally and um
because I'm a person of color I'm always
looking at at it from from that lens
anyway so I'm going to incorporate that
into the classroom I don't know where
this lady's teaching but she needs to be
fired and that's not cancel culture that
would be actual accountability she's
telling you as a science teacher as a
person of color and a science teacher I
have to figure out a way to make science
about race science has nothing to do
with race there have been bananas crazy
scientists over time who've tried to
racialize science to make it seem that
some people are less than others which I
I guess actually is what these type of
people are trying to do but do you see
again do you see and then years go by
and then they've been taught racism in
science class and they've been taught
all of this crazy stuff and boys or
girls and blah blah blah and then they
get to college and you have a teacher
that's telling you that the people who
are beheaded are the bad guys and then
next thing you know you are literally
walking down the streets of Time Square
holding up a Taliban flag and
this is I guess you could say
problematic
here's Robin D'Angelo she is a white
woman who has been uh one of the biggest
race husters I'm fairly certain she's
become a millionaire doing this charges
like 50 Grand a pop for a speech
uh this this one uh thank God we did
something funny today I needed it um
here she is suggesting that the movie
Frozen which I again it's for young I
have not seen Frozen I bet you've seen
Frozen you've probably seen Frozen Rock
seen Frozen just it's for kids but here
she is uh pointing out that Frozen is
actually promoting racism because the
ideal character is white is this idea
that children are innocent I mean
certainly born Innocent but research
shows that by age three as early as age
three they understand that it's better
to be white wow let me be clear not that
white people are better but that it's
just better to be white and let me give
you an example of of um Frozen the movie
Frozen yes it's huge this movie movie
right I I've seen little girls all over
the world with the backpacks and I mean
you can't watch that movie and not know
that the ideal is white blue eyes blonde
hair red hair that's just one
example she should be in a mental
institution she should be zooming from
Arkham Asylum these people are
completely insane I have not seen Frozen
but I am just willing to stake my career
stake any credit that you think I might
be worth on the fact that it is not out
there to promotee white supremacy my
nieces have Frozen backpacks funny she
mentions the backpacks I guess that
became a thing my nieces have Frozen
backpacks they're not white supremacists
Brock who has seen so you're an expert
in Frozen I think we can call you there
was a snowman character do you know his
name his name is Olaf okay oh Olaf
that's nice like saying Olaf uh was are
they what was he was he a white
supremacist because he was a snowman
to and these and so then there's a woman
out there there's a white liberal woman
in a city out there who says can I pay
money to see that woman talk you got to
be me uh but speaking of crazy
people let's get back to the government
for a second because what I've been
trying to show you here is that there's
a reason a generation of kids are out on
the streets calling for genocide their
brains have been broken with race and
with gender and everything else and it
is because of as clay pointed out
identity politics is because diversity
equity and inclusion that has been
pushed on our corporations and
everything else Up Is Down left is right
well here's KLA Harris she's apparently
the vice president and she is the she is
the function of identity politics right
she is only the vice president because
she is black and a woman nobody thinks
she's qualified nobody thinks that if
Joe Biden broke a hip tomorrow or fell
up the stairs again which again is a
certain skill into itself onto itself
falling up the stairs all the time
nobody is confident that this woman
could lead the world right it's a it's a
travesty uh but here she is saying that
the people who say bad things about Dei
which is modern racism those are the bad
guys environmental justice piece of this
is extraordinarily important and I will
therefore emphasize another
point there are some forces in our
country that are trying to say that it
is a bad term to talk about Dei they're
trying to do with Dei what they did with
woke and we got to pay attention to that
they're trying to suggest that it is
somehow wrong to talk about Dei
diversity equity and inclusion that it
is somehow wrong to talk about the fact
that when you look at for example the
fact that I'm the first woman of color
to be Vice President of the United
States
yep that the piece about diversity is
somehow not important it isn't
important I already yelled enough words
it isn't important lady it is the
reverse of what America is founded upon
which is why the entire leftist movement
is going after Israel right now because
if you think that when they're done
trying to convince you that the Jews are
not indigenous to the ancient land of
Israel what do you think they're going
to do in the United States right like
that's the point that is the point
nobody cares nobody should and I she
just said this is what they the left
does with everything they create words
that kind of sound good diversity equity
and inclusion in the way she well they
don't care about diversity and equity
and inclusion and look how I moved my
hand when I said it these are three very
important things and they're like this
nobody cares nobody cares I would love a
no it's not even right I was going to
say I would love a black woman who is
competent who was the vice president
it's not that I would love that I would
love a competent vice president if she
happened to be black Zippity damn dudah
you are not competent lady you have all
the wrong ideas you were hired for all
the wrong reasons dementia Joe announced
that he was hiring you for the wrong
reasons when he said I'm going to find a
black female to do it which is exactly
by the way what Gavin Newsome just did
with the with the new Senator that
replaced Diane Feinstein who died a
couple weeks ago he found a black
lesbian who lived in Maryland to become
the senator from
Cali but it continues because it's not
just again our politics now and it's not
just our education it's you know it has
rotted our corporations as well so this
is Black Rock CEO Larry thinkink and you
guys know Black Rock basically owns
virtually everything in America at this
point they're buying private homes and
they own portions of all our giant
corporations and everything else this
guy has an inordinate amount of power
and how what else are they trying to now
connect this to they they are also
trying to connect wokeness to that
basically America should not have
borders that it would be racist if we
even had borders so here watch watch
this little trick that he does uh he's
talking about immigration and how that
if we don't basically let everyone in
that it's going to cause too much wage
pressure and that would be bad in
essence for guys like him watch we are
going to uh focus on um if the whole the
whole idea about restricting immigration
big topic here in Germany big Topic in
the United
States um we are down in the United
States oh close to three million legal
immigrants we've changed the immigration
policy at the same time there's so many
job needs and in the United States we've
had close to a trillion dollars of
fiscal stimulus just beginning its
jcurve and these are huge job creators
and at the same time we have
restricted uh
immigration and as a result of it you
know we see more wage pressure so at
what cost we have in the United States a
very
protracted uh strike between the Auto
Workers and the auto companies it has
been reported that the the union is
asking for a 40%
increase so at what cost what you know
in the long R what does that mean for
jobs do more more jobs
move okay so I know that that was a
little bit technical but the point is
here he is Larry Fink in Germany
basically saying you guys should have
more immigration and we should have more
immigration in the United States now
first off the gall to say it to Germany
Germany is is crumbling because they
allowed in over a million people in the
last what seven years or so right they
have massive stress on all of their
systems they have millions now over a
million people who are not German by any
definition of what a German was right
and you might have problems with some of
the things that Germans have done in the
past uh but that's not what Germans of
of today are right and Germany has a
right to defend its borders the same way
America has a right to defend its
borders and Israel has a right to defend
its borders and Chile has a right to
defend its borders but he's basically
saying hey open up the borders because
otherwise if you don't we'll have too
much wage pressure here and we're going
to to pay those freaking Car Guys those
those unionists uh more money he's doing
just fine by the way he's the guy's got
to be worth what he's probably worth4
billion doar or something insane anyway
it's just it's just ridiculous but let's
go let's go a little bit further I have
I have to be a little fast here because
we got a couple things uh this afternoon
before I go get some more guns let's
counter what Larry thinkink the Black
Rock CEO just said uh versus a guy who
is really shaking up the system so they
will not put him on CNN RFK who has left
the Democrats just as I predicted he
hasn't become a republican yet but one
thing at a time I'll be doing an event
with him next week by the way uh here he
is I we think we played this clip for
you once if I'm not mistaken at least a
portion of it explaining how Black Rock
who Larry think is the CEO of owns a
majority of the S&P 500 companies and
now basically own nearly 60% of single
family homes in America more importantly
there's three giant corporations Black
Rock State Street and Vanguard
which own collectively they own each
other so it's really one giant
Corporation but they also own 89% of the
S&P 500 they own everything they've now
decided to buy every single family home
in America so if they stay on the
current
trajectory they will own 60% of the
homes in this country single family
homes by
2030 they literally are trying to buy
everything and and the head of it Larry
fank the CEO of black rock is on the
board of the world economic forum and
what they you know they've said we want
this great reset which is you will own
nothing and you will be happy well
they're on their way to making sure that
we don't own anything so you all
probably have heard of people who are
about to buy a home and somebody comes
in with at the last minute with a c cash
or offer and snatches off the out of the
market right and it's usually an LLC
with ambiguous name but if you trace
that up you'll find it's own by Black
Rock wow okay you know I know we have a
lot of new viewers in the last week or
so and I I want I hope you're sort of
gathering the wide lens of which I'm
doing Today's Show with that all of
these things from the crazy college kid
to the the activist Professor to the Dei
organizations to the corporations like
black rock that push unlimited
immigration that then destroy our
countries these things are all deeply
connected right now they are completely
interwoven in our culture and then we
wonder why we have people literally
calling for genocide in Time Square
right but I want to show you a little
silver lining uh you guys know I like to
end the show with the Silver Lining and
it's and it's been tough to figure out a
silver lining lately I think there's a
couple things that are that are given us
a bit of that one of them is that a
certain amount of lefties are now waking
up I think that's one thing I think
another thing is that a certain set of
people are getting a little braver to
say what they think you know I have to
say that this last 10 days it's been
sort of stressful on me personally I'm
actually at my lowest weight in about 20
years I've been working out and eating
right and everything else but I do think
it was partly a little bit of the stress
also and not sleeping well and
everything else and I have no doubt that
many of you are going through that the
Silver Lining is not uh my weight loss
uh the Silver Lining is that uh like
some people are saying what is true
they're getting they're getting more
inclined to do that there were parts of
me last week that I was like H do I even
want to do this like what am I doing I
got into this to talk about the news in
a kind of funny way and way and all that
that's I think why most of you guys love
me or support me or whatever it might be
um but now I know I'm doing what I'm
supposed to be doing like it's not even
a question right it's it's it's off the
table but the other Silver Lining is
that there are some politicians trying
to make some sense of this and
and for God's sakes people they need our
support So Nikki Haley went out there
and and said a very kind of butchered
statement that we should basically be
taking some Gaza refugees in and we
should our B people should figure it out
they should be able to delineate what
their views are and who supported Hamas
and who didn't and it's like if you
think that that's possible and if you
think America should be taking anyone
else in while we have so many problems
it's just
absolutely insane and Ronda santis who
has been this entire way I mean he's
always presidential but for the last 10
days he's been super presidential he
sent a bunch of planes from Florida to
Israel he got 300 people out okay uh out
of a war zone where's the administration
I have no idea uh here's the santis
going after Nikki Haley for her
confusion around the Gaza Refugee
situation to that point you you've made
it very clear that you do not think the
US should take in any refugees uh from
Gaza one of the reasons you gave for
that is you said that all the people in
Gaza are anti-semitic you have received
some push back on that including from
some Republicans including some of your
Republican opponents Nikki Haley for
example said today that quote America
has always been sympathetic to the fact
that you can separate civilians from
terrorists she also said that many of
these people want to be free from this
terrorist that's not the question it's
not the question of whether they're all
terrorists in Gaza they teach the kids
to hate Jews if you look at the
textbooks Israel is not on the map of
the Middle East and so this is embedded
in the culture I think it's a very toxic
culture I think that's part of the
reason Gaza turned to Hamas and the idea
you know they elected Hamas and there's
a lot of support for Hamas there so
that's a very toxic culture and I worry
about importing that to our country and
this was really bracing for me to watch
when the blood wasn't even dry off these
Israeli citizens who were victimized by
Hamas you had people in our own
country celebrating Hamas I get it Nikki
Haley would import people that's been
her her positions I get that want neily
her St but she says I would not
I'm willing to speak the truth she's
trying to be politically correct she's
trying to please the media and people on
the I don't care about that I'm going to
speak the truth and let the chips fall
where they
may and what do I say about truth all
the time notice he doesn't have to twist
himself it doesn't seem like he has to
try to like oh my God I said this that
time and but no it's completely
consistent with everything else he said
Nikki unfortunately and I I personally
like her we've she's had dinner at my
house um she unfortunately in this she's
doing something to plate a little bit of
the crazies and most politicians do that
and Ronda santis does not do that but I
want to add a little more teeth to Ronda
sanz's argument there putting aside
anti-Semitism let's say let's say again
let's say they're not anti-semites
they're okay with the Jews fine how do
you think it'll go for the chicks the
Lesbos the gay guys the bisexuals the
woke haired people or just anyone who is
liberal in nature if you bring these
people in here and couter on Tim uh Tim
Po's podcast here's the more terrifying
reality is that all all the all the
reporters that we've talked to who've
covered this said it's mostly young
women being raped by the human
traffickers it's not no it's not condoms
it's they they don't care about any of
that well that's back to your point on
the um Christian um underlying of of our
freedom and we are the freest country in
the world I mean anyone who comes from
any other country any any immigrant to
Finland makes it less white it's a very
very white country any immigrant to
America makes it less free we are
shockingly the freest country in the
world in so many ways that other
cultures do not understand and one of
the things that our media as Desh says
there is there is an operation going
it's it's I've never seen so much
Collective lying um but um the rape
cultures around the country are going to
be quite a surprise for the
feminists let me just tell you ladies
you never had it so good as with
American you know she's laughing as she
says it but the rape culture again put
aside the Jews if you are a woman if
your mother is a woman uh if your sister
is a woman or extrapolate that any which
way you know how do you know that rapes
in Britain in Germany in Sweden rapes
are off the charts women are afraid to
walk alone in big cities because they
have imported these people they have
different views as it's as it relates to
women and minorities and everything else
if you picked any of these countries any
of the Arab countries how's it going for
minorities there basically are none
how's it going for religious minorities
how's it going for Christians forget the
Jews how's it going for Christians and
all these countries there are about 20
Coptic Christians left in Egypt okay and
Egypt is a little more westernized let's
say than some of these other countries
so we all know this is true we all know
it's true and and it's only going to
work or or we're only going to stop it
if we acknowledge it right we know
what's true actually we're not afraid to
tell our friends what's true and help
them wake up and then we vote for good
people say like Aranda santis but I
don't mean to make this all about him we
need good governance across the board so
the other thing that's happening
domestically right now is obviously what
a week and a half ago Matt Gates teamed
up with all of the Democrats to take out
Kevin McCarthy you can think that was
good bad or indiffer but they knew the
new uh leader of the house uh and it
looks like it is going to be Jim Jordan
Jim Jordan I think has been an excellent
Congressman which is a very a rare
statement uh I've had him on the show
many times he really gets it on free
speech he gets it on big Tech he gets it
on wokeness and what the what the
problems are Jim Jordan about a year and
a half invited me when after the
election he invited me to speak to a
group of congressional Republicans about
big Tech like he he gets what's
happening in this country uh and it
looks like he's going to be the next
speaker we we he damn well better be and
here he is uh talking about this is
yesterday talking about what might
happen today
how many votes are you willing to go
through tomorrow are you we need to get
a speaker tomorrow um the American
people deserve to have
their Congress their House of
Representatives working um and we can't
have that happen take get a speaker so
we need to do that plus we need to be
helping our our dearest friend and
colleague uh our dearest friend and and
closest Ally of Israel we need to help
them as well going over and over again
tomorrow you expect multiple roll call
well look I feel good walking into the
conference I feel even better now we got
more people want to talk to listen to uh
and then we'll have a vote
tomorrow look if you care about America
and you think any of this matters and
who's the speaker and and what Congress
is doing it's like this guy is more
let's say to the right of Kevin McCarthy
he's a little more in the gates camp but
he fully gets it he's not a radical he's
not a racist or anything else so there
is some political solution here imagine
if we had a president like the santis
who could be clean and clear and tell us
the truth and not worry about polls and
didn't have the drama and then we had a
republican house and a leader of the
House who could then go out there and
and push for the right policies and make
those things happen we do have elections
in this country at least for now so
maybe maybe we can start getting some of
the right people I just want one more
one more thing uh this is from Benny
Johnson talking about what's going on
with Jim Jordan right now uh he wrote
Breitbart reports phone lines are
melting on Capitol Hill over the speaker
race your voices are being heard you are
making a difference in the speaker race
grass Roots energized GOP Unity behind
Jim Jordan speakership bid I haven't
seen anything like this in years one top
GOP Aid told breit Bart news they are
literally melting the phone line some
office numbers are permanently busy
thousands and thousands of people are
calling their members of Congress
demanding Jordan for speaker keep the
pressure on call your representatives
and tell them how you feel
3121 how about you give him a call
actually when I'm on the way to the gun
shop I'm going to give him a call in the
car there you go w a little of
everything today hot diggity damn if you
haven't subscribed please do at
rumble.com rubben report who knows how
long we'll be on YouTube uh if you want
to join us for a postgame show and you
want to keep us independent and
everything else uh we'll be over there
in just a second at Ruben report.
locals.com and we got to do it kind of
quick because I I got an appointment at
the gun shop so okay
[Music]
goodbye